make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and welcome back to the conclusion
of Fantastic Four and x-men or X been
fantastic for whatever you want to call
it but Franklin Richards on the cusp of
either joining the x-men or leaving the
Fantastic Four and as we know from what
we've seen so far
he joined the x-men and this is the
coolest thing right because up to this
point we basically had Franklin who was
brought to a kind of private island of
Victor Von Doom but all the roads are
the various heroes more or less brought
them here and the goal of Doctor Doom
was to basically reinstate the powers or
restore the powers of of Franklin
Richards now if those are guys who don't
you don't recall what exactly what's
going on here if Franklin's powers have
basically been waning and this is really
what kind of began in the Fantastic Four
line of comics and it's basically picked
up here the idea that Franklin is able
to tap into what's called a God power or
at least seemingly that's where
everybody with powers derives their
abilities from this kind of singular God
power source it's not really been fully
explored but whatever the case is
Franklin's access to this power has
basically been cut off and so like water
basically disappearing out of a cup his
powers are going away and so the idea of
Victor Von Doom was to basically
reinstate his connection and restore his
powers back to the way they were before
presumably even more powerful right
because Franklin is a character who's
able to alter and control reality on a
universal scale but that's only ever
really just you know a stone's throw
away from manipulating reality on a
multiversal scale the only difference
there is whether or not he can permeate
barriers between universes and they
control those barriers and then extend
his control beyond those barriers into
other universes right so Franklin has a
potential to be on the living tribunals
level in terms of the power that he
possesses he just for whatever reason
hasn't or possibly will never get there
yet right I mean we saw with Jonathan
Hickman's Fantastic Four and the future
of his character in his Avengers and New
Avengers run that Franklin never really
becomes multiversal he just becomes a
universal character who's on par with
Galactus but the other part of this is
that when the x-men followed and
basically arrived here because of course
the Fantastic Four trying to get
Franklin back the x-men are trying to
get Franklin to his side the wounded up
happening is a handful of mutants have
basically vanished are more or less
discovered here on this island in the
sense that they were put inside the
bodies or I guess the these giant kind
of doom sentinels that are basically
attacking the extranet right because the
rule was if the x-men are going to be
here they can't move beyond their
quarters right they can't explore the
island they can't leave they can't
violate any of those rules the doc
lay down which of course they did and so
that basically led to why you see these
massive sentinels here now one of the
coolest things that comes out of this
and this is usually what happens when it
comes to these kinds of stories
especially one like this that's not
necessarily flying under the radar but
one that really isn't getting a whole
lot of advertisement here is you see
these small little moments right and
this is how powers change this is how
they adjust and so what is up happening
is basically where this giant force
field is around Franklin Richards that
you've got Susan storm who tries to use
her ability to manipulate force fields
to get past it she can't and Kitty Pryde
of course can make herself light light
she can model modify her body's genetic
structure so she can pass through solid
matter and when she does that she almost
kind of taunts doom right like I made it
through your force field did you really
believe this could hold me and do
basically says I've been analyzing what
it is that you can do I can override
your powers and I can take your powers
in a direction that you never even
thought of right for example if you can
make yourself lighter than air then why
can't you just make yourself heavier
than concrete and so literally she just
goes flying through the ground right dr.
doom overrides your powers and increases
her density you never really see this
with Kitty Pryde Kitty Pryde power has
always been to move through solid matter
basically what this means is that with
Kitty Pryde going forward she can
increase her density to make herself
feel more more durable right like
bulletproof if she wanted to she could
make herself lighter than air presumably
she could even gain the power to fly
right depending on what direction mama
wants to take her character in but small
little adjustments like this now for
their part with Susan storm trying to
break through this force field she's
contacted by Emma Frost who basically
says the the missing mutants are all
inside these giant you know sentinels of
Doctor Doom and that they can't destroy
the sentinels because it'll kill the
kids and so they need help basically
deactivating them kind of shutting them
down and so Susan ends up intervening
and basically going to help now all that
happens it also leads to Nightcrawler
kind of jumping in Susan storm helping
to dismantle these these sentinels and
this is one of the cool things here but
this is why Susan storm is such a
powerful character that when it comes to
somebody like her she is in a lot of
ways a one-man army and it's one of
these things you don't really see a lot
of appreciation for when it comes to her
character right you see Susan storm
tending to the children or something
like that but the truth of this is that
she can create forcefield she's got some
measure of telekinesis right she can do
all kinds of cool things but she
literally starts breaking apart these
various sentinels so that they're
effectively destroyed but the mutants
contained within are not killed now for
Franklin Richards himself which is
really the meat and potatoes of the
story
for Franklin
it's really kind of been an existential
crisis for his character because with
with Franklin when he was a little kid
he didn't really have much reason to
question his parents right he was young
kids don't usually question what their
parents tell them but as kids grow older
they kind of begin to push barriers
right it's what we do why we become
teenagers we kind of get into that realm
where we want to become adults we want
that kind of freedom that comes along
with it and start taking our lives in
our own direction the unfortunate side
of this is that as teenagers we feel
like we have it all figured out and so
we look at the restraints that our
parents put on us as limitations as
opposed to things that can be sweet
guide us and get us to where we want to
be just in a more practical way so that
we're not possibly inflicting harm on
ourselves so for Franklin he's been
wanting to kind of break away and go out
into this world on his own and chart his
own path
the other part of this is at Reed and
Susan our parents their moms and dads
and they don't want their kid to kind of
get out there into the world I think
want their kid to stay home to be safe
they don't want things to change
right that's kind of what this is that's
what really what it comes down to they
want Franklin to get better they want
Franklin to reach his full potential but
they don't want anything to change and
in order for Franklin to get there he
has to change right he has to evolve he
has to grow and that's what kitty pryde
asks him right like she kind of breaks
in you know back into this this sort of
feel that that dr. doom had right and
then before the the armor that dr. doom
had put on Franklin fully takes his
whole in terms of modifying his power
whatever is a Doctor Doom intends to do
she basically asked Franklin what is it
that you want here and this is the one
thing that nobody asked
nobody asked Franklin Richards what he
wanted right he was just the x-men
showed up on the doorstep of the
Fantastic Four one day and said your
son's a mutant he belongs with us the
response of the Fantastic Four is no
he's our kid he belongs with us and
nobody asked Franklin who do you think
you belong with which really kind of
goes back to the the history between
Franklin and Kitty Pryde in the sense
that they've always kind of had this
longstanding friendship you know as a
result of this Franklin basically says
like I want to go with my mom but I want
to go and I want to help everybody else
alongside her and so of course this
allows Franklin to travel outside and
then kind of initiate this sort of
energy burst and then basically take out
all these little sentinels but again
Franklin's powers aren't necessarily
totally gone but they're being drained
even faster now right every time he uses
his powers they drain just a little bit
more and that's one of the things that
kind of gets hid out here is that one
doctor dooms not actually there right
like Professor X picks up on this pretty
fast and doctor dooms not there dr. doom
takes
as an offense that what the mutants have
done by showing up on his doorstep and
in violating his rules in his home is
they in turn have basically no not
really declared war on Latveria
and the official since been in the
senses like they basically pissed off
dr. doom is really what that means now
for his part he's not wrong he went to
Franklin know Franklin basically ended
up on his doorstep dr. doom threw
information to Frank them that he could
fix Franklin's powers the x-men were
chasing after him because they were like
you belong with us whether you want to
be or not we're taking mutants from all
over the world and we're bringing them
to our island they belong here right so
you know it's one of these things where
the x-men kind of imposed themselves on
Franklin and then over the fact they
believe that like all mutants belong
with them they in turn violated the
rules of doctor dooms own home right so
they walked into another man's home and
sort of telling him what's what of
course it's gonna piss off dr. doom and
so that's one of the crazy things
because with Latveria being its own
sovereign nation the actions of the
x-men is to encroach on another
sovereign nation right so they're
basically the aggressors in this
circumstance and so what this leads is
to really everybody kind of asking the
question they should have been asking to
begin with you right like Franklin what
is it that you want and Franklin's
response is I want to go learn about
myself I want to learn about mutants I
want to learn about people like me right
I don't want to just have this
discussion I don't want to just talk
about that I'm gonna live amongst my own
people and this is the hardest thing
especially for Susan storm to here
because as a parent she doesn't want him
to leave when she wants him to stay she
wants things to always be the way they
were and that's what's so cool about
this because as people we don't like
change especially comic book fans coming
book fans we hate it when things change
right that's why you always have that
movement where it's like kind of
bookstores need to be there forever even
though it's not practical it's not a
reasonable expectation people don't want
things to change and so because of that
is it's kind of a cool it's kind of a
cool way to tap into the reality of
things because even beyond comics just
as people once we kind of get into our
comfort zone we don't want things to
shift we don't want things to change I'm
actually going through that whole
process of dealing with that right now
being in Columbus on a personal level is
a cool thing to kind of see here right
and so ultimately this leads to Franklin
basically departing his family and then
traveling with the x-men now you know
about three weeks later we pick up with
Franklin who's again you know on the
island of Cocola working with beast and
beast still isn't able to figure out why
Franklin's powers are draining my why
his powers are basically going away and
so what it does is it's a quick little
throwaway thing not a great big huge
moment here just kind of showing this is
what they've been working on for the
last three weeks and ultimately Franklin
decides you
wants to go back home again at least for
dinner to see his family and you end up
having Magneto and Professor X who join
him now the other part of this is Valeri
one of the smartest people in the
entirety of the Marvel Universe and she
picked up on the fact that within this
armor of dr. doone that was put on
Franklin Richards that while everybody
else was analyzing everything going on
that what she was doing was looking at
the actual suit itself right what this
suit itself was actually capable of and
what she learned was that what Doctor
Doom had intended to do was basically
boast of the power of Franklin Richards
returned in new normal but at the same
time the siphoned some of that power off
and give it to himself and when the
question was asked why the response of
Doctor Doom is because there's a war
coming right there's a conflict coming
and the reality is that mutants do
present a credible threat to the rest of
the world and what this basically means
is that while Doctor Doom isn't
necessarily intending to go to war with
me any kind it does mean he's aware of
the fact that things could get bleak
right so in a lot of ways tapping into
the events we saw in-house and powers of
X the Doctor Doom is prepping for
whatever moves and mutants can make
later on down the line and being able to
harness the power of Franklin Richards
even if only on a minut scale would put
him miles ahead of where he is right now
and even further beyond where the mutant
population is right now - Franklin
himself and then probably Legion maybe a
few other people but it was certainly
even the odds and give Doctor Doom the
ability to protect himself and so with
Professor X and Magneto arriving at the
the residence of the Fantastic Four they
travel to visit Reed and what they talk
about here is this mutant gene cloaking
device this device that Reed had made
they basically allowed him to cloak the
gene of mutants who were out there and
even cut their powers off completely and
initially it almost seemed like they
showed up here with the intention of
saying hey like we want this like we
want to be able to take this and use
this for our own ends but that's not the
case instead they see it as an absolute
affront the worst offense Reed Richards
could have made in relation to the
mutant population and that's an
important thing to understand here
because that's not as though Reed
Richards was doing this from a place of
being vindictive but what's to stop
somebody from taking that technology of
Reed Richards and then using it for a
nefarious purposes that's why this is
important right and so because of this
magneto destroys the cloaking device and
then Charles Xavier wipes the ability
for Reed Richards to be able to make it
again right like he basically destroyed
that part of his brain so he can never
remake this thing again and so it'll be
this little piece of Reed Richards mind
that's always missing and this is huge
right because Xavier references their
time in the Illuminati and basically
says like when we were
on the Illuminati team there was a time
when after I would have taken this a
step further and I would have wiped your
mind of this meeting entirely and so as
far as your brain is concerned you never
invented that device and you have no
idea that we ever met they would just be
kind of shut out forever but the
responsive Xavier is I want you to
remember this moment I want you to
understand that I did this to you
that is a mutant population we have a
right to survive by any means necessary
and whether friend or foe will take
whatever steps we need to in order to
prevent you or anybody else from getting
in the way of our ability to use our
powers or to be a successful race out
there just making our way in the world
and so he basically tells them welcome
to the New World Order right so again
this is moving continually towards the
idea that Xavier is becoming more and
more extreme and in a lot of ways Xavier
is kind of becoming a bad guy almost
becoming like the way magneto was where
it was protecting the mutant race by any
means necessary but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here - comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the rob4 if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and that will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you